r la haute couture et c'est encore
l'économie en effet car après le rêve et
la splendeur des modèles de haute
couture que nous vous avons présenté il
ya quelques jours c'est aujourd'hui
l'heure des comptes
voici certains aspects de cette activité
économique très importante avec l'en
quête de marie-josée le picard maison de
haute saison qu'est ce que le succès
commercial puisque les vêtements eux
mêmes sont presque toujours vendu en
dessous de leur prix de revient aux
structures est un monde du rêve
l'imaginaire c'est le dernier bastion de
l'artisanat et à coutras
elle entraîne tous les industriels nous
sommes demandeurs et les industriels
sont demandeurs une industrie
florissante
les patrons papier qui permettent à
toutes les femmes qui savent coudre de
faire leurs propres vêtements une
société américaine vote 14 h est donc
les droits de reproduction un patron
papier de certains modèles choisis pour
leurs nouveautés et leur simplicité
d'exécution
la photo de la robe sera appuyée sur le
conditionnement du patron chaque saison
plusieurs modèles en haute couture et
cette saison nous en avons choisi chez
dior givenchy chez saint laurent et chez
nina ricci
quand un modèle du sud elle du succès il
se vend environ entre et c'est là une
belle question entre 10000 exemplaires
nous en sommes satisfaits et 100000
quand c'est un modèle tout à fait
exceptionnel qu'est ce que ça rapporte à
la haute couture française cela rappelle
la haute couture française et aux
créateurs puisque nos accords sont avec
des maisons de haute couture c'est la
saison bien sûr mais aussi avec quelques
grands créateurs français à peu près un
demi million de dollars par an chez
christian lacroix le nouveau grand
couturier même les modèles les plus
demandés comme ceux ci ne se vende que
deux fois car une femme assise riches
pour payer entre 30 et 300 mille francs
pour une robe ne veut pas risquer de
rencontrer une amie à billets comme elle
mais le succès de cette première
collection de haute couture un site
immédiatement les industriels à proposer
des contrats pour les saisons à venir
fabrication de prêt-à-porter fourrure
mode masculine aussi c'est de là que
viendront les profits
même si nous prenons des dix certaines
décisions rapides pour signer certains
contrats avec des partenaires
industriels et commerciaux qui dans les
diodes christian apporte son talent de
création d'édition que prenons
maintenant deux prendront leurs effets
au niveau des produits qui seront sur le
marché qu'à partir de l'automne 1988
donc c'est en fait parce que nous aurons
une pleine année de produits présents
sur certains marchés que nous pourrons
considérer que la société aura sa
rentabilité et que l'investissement
initial sera remboursé le volume
d'affaires des 24 maisons de haute
couture est globalement de 300 millions
mais le chiffre d'affaires des produits
vendus sous leur nom prêt-à-porter et
accessoires et de 18 milliards
65 pouces
non